N
WILL MAKE WORLD WAR II LOOK LIKE
A SMALL -- SMALL SKIRMISH.
JOINING ME, GENERAL KEITH
KELLOGG.
HERE IS THE MAP.
THE RED IS RUSSIA.
BLUNT AREAS UKRAINE IS
DEFENDING.
WHAT CONCERNS YOU MOST FROM THE
UKRAINIAN PERSPECTIVE?
>> FIRST OF ALL, THE UKRAINIANS
ARE FIGHTING WITH INCREDIBLE
COURAGE AND LEADERSHIP STARTING
WITH ZELENSKY.
THE RUSSIANS HAVE STALLED OUT.
MY CONCERN IS THEY WILL LOAD UP
AND THEY WILL HAVE TO GO AFTER
KYIV.
KYIV IS THE CROWN JEWEL.
THAT'S THE KING ON THE CHESS
BOARD.
THEY HAVE TO TAKE KYIV THAT'S
THE CENTER OF GOVERNMENT AND
WHERE ZELENSKY IS AT.
I DON'T THINK THEY CAN TAKE IT
WITHOUT RUBBLIZING IT LIKE THEY
DID IN MARIUPOL AND KHARKIV.
JUST SHELL THE HECK OUT OF IT.
LOOKING AT THE MAP, THEY ARE
ABOUT AS EXTENDED AS THEY CAN
BE.
IF YOU GO TO THE MAP, IT LOOKS
LIKE HE WILL FOCUS ON EASTERN
UKRAINE, NOT THE WEST.
HE DOESN'T HAVE THE TROOPS TO
MOVE TO THE WEST.
IF HE CAN TAKE KYIV, I AM NOT
SAYING HE CAN, IF PUTIN CAN TAKE
IT, I THINK HE WILL SAY LET'S
CALL IT A DAY.
I OWN THE EASTERN PART OF
UKRAINE, YOU HAVE GOT WESTERN
PART.
THAT YOU GIVES YOU THE SANCTUARY
HE WANTS.
BUT IF HE DOESN'T GET IT,
DOESN'T TAKE KYIV, HE HAS A
MAJOR PROBLEM.
THE WEST IS BADLAND TERRITORY.
HE WILL EXTEND HIS LOGISTICS
LINES AND FACING A LOT OF NATO
ALLIANCE OUT THERE.
I THINK HE WILL CALL IT A DAY.
IF THIS WAS A PRIZE FIGHT RIGHT
NOW, ZELENSKY IS WINNING ON
POINTS.
BRIAN: LOOK AT THE SOUTH.
THEY HAD DONBAS AND CRIMEA,
THAT'S ALL RED.
I HEAR THIS IS JUST TREMENDOUS
STREET-TO-STREET FIGHTING.
MYKOLAIV, THEY ARE FIGHTING LIKE
SPARTANS.
BUT THEY ARE TRYING TO BLOCK
ODESA.
THERE IS A SENSE IN FAR POLE
THAT THEY COULD LOSE THE CITY --
THERE IS A SENSE IN MARIUPOL
THAT THEY COULD LOSE THE CITY
THIS WEEKEND.
EVEN THOUGH WE KNOW HIS GOAL WAS
TO WIN IN TWO OR THREE DAYS AND
IT'S BEEN 24.
COULD YOU SEE THAT?
>> I CAN.
HE WILL REALIZE THAT HE CANNOT
TAKE ALL OF UKRAINE TO THE WEST.
HE WILL REALIZE WHAT'S HAPPENING
WITH THE SANCTIONS AND THE WORLD
PRESSURE ON HIM, HE WILL TRY TO
CUT THE BEST DEAL HE CAN.
AS LONG AS WE CAN KEEP ZELENSKY
ALIVE WE ARE OKAY.
A FEW DAYS A GO THE HAGUE VOTED
13-2 TO SAY THIS IS GENOCIDE,
IT'S A WAR CRIME.
I THINK IT BIGGEST ONE IS
UKRAINE IS PUSHING BACK.
IF ZELENSKY CAN HOLD ON TO KYIV
AND HOLD THAT CITY, I THINK THEY
WILL WIN THIS FIGHT.
IF YOU GO INTO A CITY, YOU WANT
A 3-1 ADVANTAGE WHEN YOU GO IN A
FIGHT.
THEY WILL NEED A 10-1 ADVANTAGE
AND HE DOESN'T HAVE THE TROOPS.
HE'S BRINGING TROOPS IN FROM
MOSCOW.
BRIAN: DO YOU HAVE ONE OUT OF
THE BOX THOUGHT YOU WANT TO
LEAVE US WITH TODAY ABOUT
FINLAND?
>> WE NEED SOMEBODY TO TALK TO
PUTIN.
I WOULD GO TO THE PRESIDENT OF
FINLAND WHO KNOWS PUTIN AND HAS
BEEN WITH HIM.
HE'S A VERY SEASONED POLITICIAN.
HE'S THE ONE WE SHOULD GO TO AND
SAY LOOK, BECOME THE
INTERLOCUTOR FOR US.
WE CAN'T WAIT TO TALK.
BRIAN: WE HAVE TO FIGURE OUT THE
RIGHT TERMS AND GET SOM